[Music]
what's up with it brother
life is good man no good place nah man
as long as
you know i just need like four to five
core people to be healthy
and then i'm good how you doing man
never better man that's good man it
makes me happy
and everybody's running around making my
rounds how you how are you thinking
about
like it's super interesting for me from
afar and obviously
you know just in culture i know about
you and then obviously kenny austin's a
good friend and i know all about that
and boyd and everything
it's super interesting to me because i
feel like
you're you're story and how you roll
is why i like hip-hop so much because i
think of it more as
hustling and entrepreneurship than even
necessarily the music
absolutely how are you thinking about
how ridiculous your opportunity is the
next 30 40 years
because you you're you've got so much
[ __ ] leverage
right like people really talk good [ __ ]
behind your back that know you
right like whether it's cliche beats by
dre
or like what i'm up to which is buying
brands like
your ability to create real wealth
creation is unique in your space
and i was really excited to meet you
just to get a sense of
how you're thinking about that because
for example like i think you should buy
i think you should buy wheaties right
for like like i'm being serious
like that's what i think you can do i
think a lot of kids are gonna make money
but you're an entrepreneur like when i
look at you i look at you entrepreneur
comma
artist at least from afar i don't know
you well enough yet but it's real
obvious to me
you know you can you could always you
could always sense your own from afar
right
that's but that's how it works though
you feel the energy i mean for me it's
just like
that that was my thing i even got into
music off of being an entrepreneur
that's what well that's
i know enough to know like i feel like
you're using music as your gateway
setup for your mogul ambitions right
it's a soundtrack
just to keep them tuned in so you can do
other things leverage [ __ ] leverage
yeah it's a vehicle
it's definitely good one thing that's
really cool too that i want to know is
like
what we do and like how we do all these
brand partnerships and different i feel
bad about other people we can get them
in here yeah let's get them in here
yeah i know i noticed dude was like
let's get out but like we'll make make
rude for that
take all this garbage out
you know that's that's you say wheaties
huh i see that yeah man
my whole thing is like what am i man
real pleasure
howard thanks good take a seat right
there uh
my whole thing i was telling a-rod the
other day he's like i'm we're gonna make
an app and make this money me and jayla
i'm like dude
you need to buy [ __ ] fruit of the
loons and put your [ __ ] sexy asses in
those underwear with j.lo
and buy that for 130 million and then
sell it for a billion
like every you know even what you did
with with avion like
i think it's like now it's very obvious
to me that the next step
in the game of the thing that drives our
culture which is [ __ ] hip-hop
is first it was like you got a couple
you got pennies
then then then they became silver then
it went to paper
but you know and you know this and
you've done it
probably outside of like three or four
other artists better than anybody the
next step is [ __ ]
for real for real and that's why i do
think like wheaties like
uh what i'm building here is i want to
build a machine a death star
and then i want to buy tylenol or
wheaties or
k-swiss that's why i did a collaboration
with them i want to buy
big-ass [ __ ] businesses and run them
through my
culture machine which is different than
your culture machine and make
real [ __ ] economics timbo's
you need to buy timberland the brand and
[ __ ] reboot it
because you're not going to put up all
380 million i mean i don't know your
paper but like that's a lot
but there's a lot of people you can own
25 of it
and [ __ ] get you know 15 people to
put up 30 million dollar checks each
and then buy timbo for 280
and sell it for 3.1 billion seven years
later that's the next step
if you're really playing what at least i
think you have the potential to play
it's nice to make two bucks a bottle on
some [ __ ] cognac
but like that's a whole different thing
than buying starter
rebooting you see what's going on with
champion champion was [ __ ] 24 months
ago
you saw what's going on fila you see
what's going on tommy hilfiger
like where's [ __ ] nautica right now
garbage you [ __ ] get behind it
and get [ __ ] atlanta behind it and
it's back
and you're not gonna and what you and a
lot of your homies aren't thinking about
just yet and i didn't think about this
back in the day either is
you don't have to put up all the money
you need to be the machine that it goes
through you'll put up
5 million a million i don't want to
count your money you could put up some
money
but you can raise the rest and get 20
for being the machine
right that's the next step man
honestly that's like that's where that's
where you buy the hawks
instead of sitting courtside
talking i really think you've got that
potential from afar
i really do i think there's four or five
people that can and i know you can
because
you are businessman first
a lot of people are now saying it
because it's cool but they're artists
first comma they want to be an
entrepreneur because it's
the flavor of the decade but that should
be over once everybody loses their money
always does always does that's right
exactly
but you need to be thinking that way i'm
locked in
i'm definitely i mean i've never thought
wheaties but [ __ ]
you need like right like like i think
people think too much
when you're cool you think about cool
products but like there's nothing wrong
with
blow pops and you can make a lot of
things cool too
yeah like like your case was like gary
this is gary's case swish shoe
dope and you know a lot of people on hip
hop would go to nike or adidas or
whatever but when you went to k-swiss
it's kind of like
because i want to buy i want to buy pony
and get spud webb's ass to put them back
on and
bring it back you know like nostalgia
nostalgia's underpriced that's my
biggest thesis
so like what did you grow up eating what
did you grow up wearing that's not
relevant now
first thing i did when i did the k-swiss
joint was i went on google and found
pictures of
[ __ ] dr dre iced tea
everybody wearing [ __ ] k-swiss says
mike tyson in his prime
because i remember right how old are you
38. right so you might remember it a
little bit but i don't know
40 something
but that's what i thought which means
you should remember right and that's
what
that's what i'm spending all my time on
build a [ __ ] big ass [ __ ] machine
and then whatever the [ __ ] i buy deploy
that [ __ ] army behind it and go hard
because it's very obvious culture will
accept anything back
you just gotta make it contemporary and
when you
and the way you have leverage like i
meet businessmen that are in a fashion
business in italy and they're like
when i'm in atlanta i go and meet jeezy
and take a picture and like
like you have something for real
it's just the truth so that's what
that's the bill though
this is my gallery you know he already
put me in pocket one time
so i can imagine that man you sit down
and you start building yeah man and that
you're talking about avion yeah my man
i'll
you know that happened because me and
[ __ ] ken austin sat there
yeah like like it's way beyond that
that's five [ __ ] years ago
like it's like what i'm talking about is
like it's way better than it was back
then
we didn't have you and i didn't have the
leverage with kenny back then
meaning we were still in endorse social
media
entrepreneurs like you and me we still
were in in endorsement mode
now we don't need now you can sell
[ __ ] [ __ ] direct to consumer
right like you make that hoodie you
don't need macy's you don't need target
you don't need walmart
shit's about to get crazy like the
people that have the leverage
are the people closest to the people got
it
because everything in the middle is
commoditized now you don't have to be
good and go to bentonville and get
walmart to put you on
you don't have to be on television and
spend 10 million dollars
so now that the middle has been
commoditized and you and me
and all the leverages go into us
we're just talking about cat that david
good people and like that's exactly like
that's what he's doing like the sweater
the hoodie like
the snowman i know everything like no no
no right the craziest thing
so to me the snowman is like go buy an
ice cream brand
and parlay that [ __ ] right like go buy
like
go buy a [ __ ] ice cream brand and buy
it from unilever when they [ __ ] it up
for like 49 million make it hot and sell
it back to [ __ ] coca-cola for 280 and
make
240 quick and that's real money
my man right here right cool kid right
look what he's wearing he's wearing vans
like that was four four years ago that
brand has got no pulse
but it did 12 years ago 19 years ago
remember op and jams and [ __ ]
we can sit here and go down memory lane
all those opportunities
that's how i'm thinking the craziest
thing is like when when you start
working with avion right
your first tweet or your first ig post i
don't know if anyone told you this
the sales went up like crazy in detroit
and that makes sense
because not only you know atlanta
whatever but he's hot in detroit or
whatever everyone has their own cities
right
but where you took that brand is
unbelievable
and like when we do all these brand
deals a lot of times they don't last a
year two years and like how many years
that's because that's because the one
thing with him that's different
is the youngsters [ __ ] with him on a
respect level that's different
that's why i'm gonna win it's not how
cool or big i'm gonna be
17 million instagram followers in four
years is gonna be great
it'll be cool but it's not gonna make
people
like i'm not gonna be able to move
america to all of a sudden by myself
give a [ __ ] about whatever the [ __ ] i
deploy that against
the thing you have is the tentacles as
an entrepreneur in business
man within people that are moving
culture
it doesn't matter what the migos are
doing it matters who the migos look
up to that's where scale comes in man
you understand that's how entrepreneurs
grew up 100 what of course when
facebook grew up listening to you 100
yeah it's the influence it's not your
own sheer you [ __ ] like i [ __ ] man
you can move a product with
without you ever posting it on social
ever once
it's the people underneath you that [ __ ]
with you
at scale for real who are moving the
needle
and you've got favors in your pocket i
know i've done a lot of homework
you got favors in your pocket so favors
are smart when you're going for a
billion
right like if you go and spend you know
if you go raise capital from a bunch of
wealthy people and have 280 million
dollars and then go and buy
fila and the mission is for the next
four years seven years
real time not 12 months to get that and
sell it to nike for 2.3 billion because
they're whack in 2029 and they need a
hot brand
that's when you call in every [ __ ]
favor that's what i do
all i'm doing right now is trying to
bring value cause
one day i'm gonna care about something
for real
[Laughter]
you understand that's where i'm at like
i'm not
you understand i got leverage with
everybody i'm just giving giving even
with you like through it like that's
give give give give your best
and the best part for me is and i don't
know you the key to that whole system
is not to be disappointed when people
don't come through
i've got i don't know you and i don't
and i know i'm unusual with this like i
can do everything for boyd i've done a
lot for him
and if i asked him for a favor for real
in two years and he said no
for some reason that doesn't [ __ ] with
me
it cripples my dad cripples him
but for me i'm like i'm not gonna worry
about what was going through his mind
i got time to analyze what was going
through his mind at this minute where he
didn't understand the score
it's like that bronx tale movie where
the guy's like you got off easy because
that kid owes you 20 bucks you know he's
a piece of [ __ ] remember that little
scene
like that's how i think about it like if
i go in for the ask and it doesn't come
through
i might be sad for a hundredth of a
second because be like [ __ ]
you know like i helped that dude for
real like why the [ __ ]
you know what's that
because looking back or defense loses
it's prevent defense in football
you've been winning the whole game and
now you decide with two minutes left to
change your defense
because there's two minutes left and
they score a touchdown it's like classic
that's life
i don't care who stole money for me like
just saves me time to go on the offense
so that's what i'm trying to collect i'm
trying to collect
real partnerships and real friends for
20 you know we may be in our 40s but
like
i [ __ ] with people dude who built this
real estate project for 28 billion
dollars
he's 70 [ __ ] seven and he's i talked
he texted me just now he's like let's do
saturday morning breakfast
steve ross owns the dolphins like he's a
straight [ __ ] gangster he's got as
much energy as you and me wants it
still hungry as [ __ ] 77.
when you're an entrepreneur you're not
playing on your looks
you're not playing on your swag
you know so i think we got 40 more years
of like real game time
right the real 40. i think so we're much
smarter than we used to be
you know like that's the best part of
not being an athletes get slower
entrepreneurs get smarter
i've thought about it like that yeah we
definitely got the bill
we should do sunday morning
one thing you can help me with i'm
looking to go hard at atlanta next year
okay i'm going to my next shoe drop i'm
definitely going to launch party there
i'm going to go to two to three uh hawk
games a y
in in the back half of the next year
during the season sick courtside just
like
atlanta's like atlanta is literally the
seed of culture
in my opinion it really is because
that's where hip-hop's culture's
epicenter is and then hip-hop's culture
becomes white kid's culture
it's just it's the bedrock so i'm gonna
make a real commitment to it
we're going to be coming through a lot
yeah for sure every time
does he enrich yourself know each other
you never met yourself
so i'm managing producer richie south
he's future and thug's new guy
he did all the smoke and he did i am
with chris brown
he's just the south side he's off okay
yeah he's with with that kid
yeah he's cool with south side but he's
with future every day okay
but uh he says we'll start obviously you
should meet him
legend you should meet him it would be
great i think i hit up a
stone cold tried to set it up last time
in atlanta but i hit salomon but
you're going to meet him some days
that's inevitable but you know you
should meet him he's a good kid
coming up real okay what else what can i
help you guys with
what else is on your mind because i know
i went but
i've been waiting for this meeting i
want to tell you what's on my mind i
didn't even wait i just would love to
you know just
continue to build you know i mean and
stay in pocket because
i definitely listen man you can hit me
every minute this is my framework
this is a advertising agency we work
with
all the biggest brands budweiser all
sorts of brands right but it's a front
i literally think of this whole 150
million dollar company
it is i really i'm being dead serious
this entire 150 million dollar company
is like a cleaners in the bronx in 1972
and downstairs is the casino that's what
this is
everything i do here is not about making
money let me
let me chop it up a different way we're
gonna do a buck 50 in revenue this year
i'm making 1 million
1.7 million in profit i'll make more
money speaking six times this year
then this whole company will make me
because i'm investing into the [ __ ]
machine
so that when i buy you know bubblicious
right i'm going to be able to turn it
and make everybody [ __ ] with it
right because you got you got the
machine the machine
right i think you have a weird machine
from afar
you have a how people [ __ ] with you
machine
i think if you organize you might really
be able to build something really
substantial man you're sitting
in the epicenter of i think
china's coming up but like america is
still the brand in the world
and i do think this is the [ __ ] like
place
but [ __ ] man i think atlanta's culture
and i think you need to be super
thoughtful about how much leverage that
actually is
i think you guys take it for granted
because you know
it just feels normal you're so in it it
feels normal you take it for granted
like i just think it's [ __ ]
really matters like at a level that
[ __ ] confuses me
meaning like just watching it go from
you know hella read and okay like just
watching it
my whole life like the leverage is so
real
the thing with the thing that [ __ ] with
me the most is the difference between 21
savage
russ the migos like danny glover like
the hollywood [ __ ] that's happening in
the [ __ ]
the suburbs like there's so much really
happening
that's what i'm good at i'm good at
people's attention
that's why i invested in facebook and
twitter and uber before everybody else i
knew it was going to happen
i really think you guys can build some
big ass businesses
i'm all open i'm i'm totally ill
do you know what private equity is good
find
every single private equity firm in
atlanta and just start networking
really understand it because the new
version of private equity
is what i think you need to be thinking
about private equity people
would get everybody to put up the money
they would keep 20 of the action
and they went to harvard and you know
yale and had finance degrees and worked
at goldman sachs
i think the next version of them yeah
man there's just something you know
music is one of the four to five things
that
humans give a [ __ ] about right
and fashion's another one and now you're
on like two of the [ __ ] five things
people give a [ __ ] about
so one thing i would give you a huge
piece of advice
don't let any vulnerability happen in
atlanta
from your status of who you are to the
people that are 28
to 31 26 to 35
you need to make sure 15 to 25 looks at
you the same way they did
i didn't bring up richie south for us i
brought up richie for
you do you understand
what you have leverage same reason that
all the [ __ ]
you know hip-hop kids coming through and
meeting with me i have leverage as an
entrepreneur
no [ __ ] athlete and [ __ ] artist
gave a [ __ ] about me four years ago
now entrepreneurship matters now they do
my biggest piece of advice
is get somebody yourself i don't know
your crew to really have your ear to all
the [ __ ] and get to those kids
super [ __ ] early and just give them
love
build [ __ ] real leverage like i'm on
[ __ ] face time with gunna every day
you know like get in early because then
giving them real love
and then they're going to be the [ __ ]
framework of the thing that you're going
to actually want to pull off
and you have leverage you [ __ ] dm
[ __ ] young thug
18 months ago he loses his [ __ ] mind
less today
it's really real you know that was
that's
that's really matters to me because
that's a big leverage point for you
i get it totally of course because it's
what you [ __ ] did to get here
but this is the time you triple down on
that [ __ ] and what most people do at
this point is go the other way
they get fancy all right i'm going to
get my hands dirty
i'm saying i'm ready to jump in here
first man
we're definitely going to have to build
definitely i'm i'm with that totally
you know what are you guys working on
now like what's on your mind obviously
i've seen some of
the new project and all that so putting
the project out just finished uh
a compound in atlanta which is you know
uh
studio uh you know just a whole compound
so it's gonna be easy to run
run the younger guys do this we've got
two rooms just a mute goddess
[ __ ] you got that now you need to get
every [ __ ] like i don't know who the
[ __ ]
ear is in this crew all of you nobody
like you need to [ __ ] get every one
of those kids through
it's just leveraged
because he's the gatekeeper yeah but
he's he's the guy but i had his
conversations with him every day
how so same conversation yeah that we
need to get these kids through
and what do you think got to be
selective or you're cool with it
seriously what are you what's the pretty
much part
go back and forth you know i bring
something to the table we have the weed
of course so that's pretty much out the
it
that's my that's my own my 2018 plan is
to
really just get my my hands down you're
a straight [ __ ] legend to these kids
but you know what's crazy and people get
caught people get caught
because they you can get irrelevant real
fast
like you don't want to know how many 17
year olds in atlanta don't really know
what it happens just like that
you did it to somebody else
you know like like i was i had a crazy
meeting with 50 cent once where
he was like trying to say something and
i was like you're not as famous as you
think which was a little bit of a
mistake because he got mad but
you know got a little aggressive but i
was trying to help him
i was like what the [ __ ] do you think
you did i'm like big daddy kane wasn't
cool for four years i remember
you know like it just happens real quick
that's your leverage showing them love
on the come up
and you know what's gonna happen you
know
we all know what's happening if when
it's going good for coach k
now right like if he's gonna make a
decision to try to put somebody on for a
minute you gotta at least take the bet
it could become biggie it could become
mace
but it doesn't matter it's 50 50.
what you didn't want to waste three
hours
got it it's just math
you know a machine is going to try to
make him good he may suck
he may be great but you know the energy
of the machine is going to be behind it
you know the crews that are winning you
know if metro boomin's going to go make
a [ __ ]
album with somebody and you haven't
heard about him you better [ __ ] meet
him
he may be great he may not but you know
he's gonna have a 50 50 chance
and it's definitely worth three hours of
you [ __ ] with him and teaching him
as the legend somebody needs you need to
own that
there shouldn't be a single [ __ ]
artist out of atlanta that comes out in
over the next seven years
who doesn't reference you in their
second album of like thanks for the
support
because that's when you buy [ __ ]
that's when you buy something and get
all and you cash in those chips
then all of a sudden you make 700
million dollars on the flip
got it all on just what first of all
they're gonna help you
that three hours with somebody that's 19
that's [ __ ]
raw and got a different perspective
they're just gonna give you a different
perspective too and you're going to know
exactly what to do with it which is
going to affect your next project
it's like what you're doing
times a thousand
or 113 but more than one
well i like the way you put those
numbers together
but you know what i mean it's there for
you man if you don't do it somebody else
is going to take it
you know yeah by the way that's what i'm
good at
well that's you know honestly i'm giving
you advice based on feedback i've been
getting from other people like
it's just [ __ ] time right it's if you
like people love to say they're gonna
get their hands dirty
but then you actually got to get your
hands dirty like it's not sometimes
you're
you know you're doing mogul life like
sometimes get you know
this kid who's got like once like you
know you're taking risks
your time is your [ __ ] biggest asset
but it's where all the leverages
think about everybody who didn't [ __ ]
with 21 savage
27 months ago that's like [ __ ] i should
have taken that
all meeting is that right yeah how about
what
it's him i heard him on a few records
i'm like
like records you wouldn't even i heard
him on the bad boy right or not
how long do you know bad bunny oh i saw
him in your video
that's another thing you know what's an
interesting thing for them the latino
stuff
i know that to me is the next wave
i met him in miami he came to atlanta uh
reached out i want to put up on the show
called the show we talked a little bit
we've been talking about people trying
to make music with those guys we had
that conversation
you know he doesn't speak a lot of
english right yeah
there's only so much you can accomplish
right do you know somebody in this camp
did this speak sick i know a lot of
people on the dike jay valve
camp and a bunch of those people but
yeah but yeah i know people who speak
english in that world
right now i'm just saying as far as
that's that's been the biggest thing was
like
is trying to just you know communicate
with him there's a startup i just looked
at that's two years away from you having
ear pieces that you can't even see and
literally every language somebody speaks
you just translate
and back and forth that's it i'm telling
you five
two years they say five years from now
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] cracked
it's like hurt her
yeah cracked go to china put in the
[ __ ] thing be like oh cool yeah
look
don't get fancy listen i love you and p
diddy i love it it's [ __ ] mogul life
it's iconic [ __ ]
that 19 year old girl in alpharetta
doesn't give a [ __ ]
in fact that bunny probably worships you
if you're in his [ __ ] they all
worship you as long as you educate them
i gotta go
i gotta go to the charity event let's
get this card out i don't have a
what's your number i gotta know what
you're listening to in the morning what
you got
[Music]
um
[Music]
you